[Music]
[Applause]
W hello hey hi come on in great to meet
you hi Casey Matt Matt yeah Matt Walsh
that's me you're Matt Walsh I'm Matt
Walsh the one and
only okay
um can you hold on one second absolutely
okay hold on one second get my stretches
perfect I I was a little surprised when
he first walked in because I I thought I
was working with Matt Walsh from vep no
I like what do you mean no it's no it's
not not Walsh can okay and then my
lawyer informs me that I am
contractually bound to work with this
Matt Walsh
so yeah all right well everything good
good yeah you know it was a really good
first meeting I thought I think uh Casey
got a little star
struck but I always try to remind people
that I'm just a regular guy you know
okay well let's just see let's just try
some stuff let's just see what you've
got okay so let's just start very very
simple today and we'll just hold this
Rhythm nice and tight okay it's kind of
a this thing that you're doing nope it's
not front to back it's a really side to
side this what you're doing you could
mirror me actually you know just like
you say mirror you mean right like if if
I if you were looking at a mirror and I
was looked like you okay you want me to
look at you in the mirror and then do
what make it look just like I'm doing
but imagine I'll do it bigger so if that
isn't clear I mean just out to the side
it's just a step out to the side yeah I
think that was it right there did you
see what I did I I did see that um
that's not to the side at all so well it
depends on where you're standing it's
someone's side uh it's going great so
far I think you know professional
dancing I always say it's a little bit
like uh riding a bike and uh you got to
take some practice to learn how to do it
and then if you're not doing it for a
while you just got to sort of shake the
rust off and and get back into the swing
of things you know what let can I can I
give you a note sure yeah uh your
instructions a little unclear and I find
that in dance it's it's better to be
very clear about what you're saying so
okay I've never seen a more
uncoordinated person in my entire life
you're right' been abstract okay did you
want to try partnering what do you mean
partnering one dancer and another dancer
dance together they act as partners and
they move as one so we're doing this
well no I I was just using I was
gesturing my hands for you know are you
looking what I'm doing right now cuz
this this is the whole thing we could do
with anyway so we're just going to try a
basic hold I can't I'm married so I
don't want to that's why I have the
wedding ring on so okay but partner
dancing does require
Partners to interact if you would feel
more comfortable with a male partner we
could no
I'm okay I'm not so okay okay well even
though I dance I'm not
gay je okay it's really funny you know I
wouldn't say that uh they have no shot
but it's a little unfair to the other
contestants cuz I have such a long uh
history in the dance world uh but the
thing is you know I'm here for two
reasons one is to express myself and two
is just uh to have
fun you know say anything about the left
leg right because the left leg does
nothing but you're standing on the left
leg so it's not doing nothing you want
to try that yeah okay show me one more
time did you want to show me some moves
that you are comfortable with you know
uh I know the macarina I'm kind of known
for that at
weddings we don't ever want to do that
that's not even the macarina well it is
Miss the macarina that's actually not it
at all that dance has a song that
explains am I instructing now is that
what's going on are you the celebrity or
am I that's the question so I think it's
me I don't know if you're a
celebrity do you want to work on upper
body okay okay perfect all right so
let's just work on some this is called
portter which means Carriage of the AR
portter that's French for Carriage of
the arm so we just want to have a good
structure and Grace when we dance what I
would love is if the uh instruction
could remain in English which is the
language that I speak so okay um so
let's start with our arms we're going to
make a circle this is called first
position that looks like you're driving
like a car okay it's more Baltic you
know it's really supposed to be kind a
little bit of like this like that's not
it that is nothing that is zero but
that's a thing that's a thing that we
could do and we're doing a little looks
like you're giving the air like a
headlock and that's not that's not a
move it could be anywhere it could be
no let's okay let's go back to our our
upper body upper body upper so the so
the arms I no I'm not going to TCH I'm
just going to like you know I'm going to
make the air show which part of your
body I want you to use your two
appendages coming from the shoulder
that's what we're going to just see if
those can make a interesting classical
shape that's not that's not it that's
nothing like what I'm doing I'm just
going to base some stuff off of what
you're doing so
okay I'm feeling good about this you
shouldn't though cuz that's that doesn't
it does not look well again my my
background is is in interpretive dance
right I'm interpreting this to be bad
this is this is bad you think he could
maybe win the entire competition okay so
arms and legs
together you know just have fun just
loosen up and you can use your whole
body and have fun I am having fun me
too look I think after the world sees
this performance they're going to know
that when it comes to dance there's a
new sheriff in town if you're really
feeling it and then all of a sudden
you're like ooh I'm going to do
something amazing and you just go nice
and you like nice for the crowd I've
done that the Dance Floor absolutely all
right all right all right we got
somewhere okay let's see
it oh
God I think I got it all righty I feel
pretty good about
that I I'm done I'm done for today okay
just take
[Music]
five